okay and then one question people may
come up with is how what you're
proposing is different from the
classical AI program of symbolic logic
and so on so that's a good question well
I think there are a number of reasons
why these classical AIA programs had
trouble and in in the work that we need
to do in order to achieve system to
performance we want to avoid some of
these pitfalls we want to make sure that
those systems will be able to generalize
efficiently in large scale the the the
concepts that we want to learn need to
be grounded in with system one in in
low-level perception in action we we
want to keep the power of generalization
of the distributed presentations we want
to make sure that the kind of search
that is involved in things like
reasoning and planning can be done
efficiently whereas the the classical
approaches require a huge number of
explorations of many trajectories of how
things could unfold or how you could
combine concepts rules and so on and
finally we need to make sure we build
systems that can properly handle
uncertainty in the world and machine
learning has been doing a pretty good
job at that up to now but we want to
achieve these extra goals that we're not
very doing during very well at like
systematization that I explained
factorizing the knowledge or at least
some of it that the learner is acquiring
in small exchangeable pieces to get
discriminatory advantage that I've been
talking about and that includes being
able to manipulate variables things that
you do naturally in programming and in
in logic formulations dealing with
instances that that are associated with
more general categories if you want and
you know having references and
interaction things that don't seem
natural in the neural net world but as
I'll try to convince you we now have
actually built the tools for doing that
in in deep learning using attention
mechanisms